please welcome the executive culinary
director and host of the cooking show
on vice best channel it's faraday
sat again it's so nice to be back here
with you
sarah day i i basically did not play it
cool
i was like when's our next date hey you
know what i like to book early so this
is awesome
let's do this have you ever had this
before by the way i've only ever seen it
and i've never had it
and if your crunchwrap told me anything
it's
you're gonna have to pry this out of my
hand all right all right well this is
good so
essentially it's like a bag of corn
chips that you're filling up with
chili um in the midwest with a walking
taco it's um
it's more so like like ground beef it
seasons kind of like tacos so
that's what we're doing right now we're
building our chili so we've got our
onions and garlic going
and we're gonna add ground cumin paprika
chili powder uh oregano and some salt
right on in there look how beautiful
that is i mean it really is
and it smells amazing so we're just
gonna dump that right dump that in there
and it's just gonna like
flood the whole studio and your kitchen
at home this is the most
fragrant dish also just in general i
think that like this the smell of
onion and garlic yeah together when my
when i was a kid we're gonna add the
tomato paste by the way when i was a kid
tomato um
my dad would be cooking dinner and we
would smell the onion and the garlic and
you're just like
what is that odor and it's just you're
like this is like
make that and like your whole family
will love you it's pretty good
so yeah the walking taco also i think
that like like any good thing
in the us it was invented essentially at
like a county fair
the world's fair type thing right all of
those good things
and i think this was like the 1982 one
is what i've heard i used to go to this
one called the pomona fair
um outside of los angeles and i remember
hearing for the first time about like a
fried avocado
and i was like i want one that's very
california of course they're going to
have
calories fried avocado there um the
tomato paste has gone in yeah and
i always like just cook the tomato paste
a couple minutes just to get that like
get it kind of caramelized a little bit
and yeah the
ground beef right on in there now i
think that like a lot of people have
their own chili recipe
and if you have your own chili recipe
that you love like use that i mean i
think that
some people don't put beans in there so
we're putting beans in ours right now
exactly
you know like texas style chili like
they're i want to be using
my chili yeah yeah throw the beans in
we're going to throw beans in
we're going to throw in tomatoes pureed
tomatoes we're going to do some
beef broth as well and don't forget
we're going to also add
some beer in here whatever beer you kind
of like i like you know maybe a lighter
one
you can add the whole one or it keeps
them out and have enjoy
yourself also and then faraday do you
reduce the liquid
you're going to reduce this so this is
going to cook for like an hour and a
half
two hours whatever it's gonna just build
so much flavor and don't forget
most of these kind of stews always taste
better the next day
and the longer you cook them the more
kind of compounded those flavors are
gonna be and it's just gonna be
even better so my favorite pork tacos i
won't even serve them
until they've been in the fridge
overnight exactly
any kind of stew like that this is gonna
sit here it's gonna cook
um i mean everyone's gonna end up eating
this later and they're gonna be
so happy but we're going to build some
walking tacos now so
so yeah we've got our little bag of
chips and i think that like you know
part of this is that like the joy of
being able to top it with anything you
want you know
um i mean what how do you top your chili
normally
well also i love like a baked potato bar
so like
doing fixins and fillings is just like i
would say it's my
kind of bag but i guess that would be a
little pun intended
i'm gonna throw on some sour cream we're
gonna do
some shredded cheddar um yeah some white
onion if you'd like
i love raw onions me too right big raw
onion fan i love a little cilantro
yes i'm gonna freshen it up with some
lime
yeah this is gonna be delicious it's
squirting everywhere there you go
okay oh my gosh i don't know whether to
use a fork or a spoon i'm going spoon me
too
oh yeah i mean you're gonna have the
crunch of the you know corn chips in
there
i'm making sure to kind of get every
element in my bite
too i'm getting mainly sour cream
because it's my favorite part
oh my god we did it again
faraday not too bad right
this is so incredible thank you i've
always wanted to try the walking taco
and i've never had the privilege
and i see what all the fuss is about
it's amazing it's amazing walk around
and eat it you know faraday what's next
what are we going to do next that like
you
we can empower to cook at home oh my
gosh we have so many things okay
we i almost feel like we should stick
with this like world's fair stuff and
maybe we'll do like funnel cakes or
something
sure you know fried avocados fried
avocados
why not you know what i've never done at
home and it's one of my favorite foods
also is a corn dog
oh a corn dog yes i love a corn dog oh
yeah
and you can make them with vegan dogs
too yeah you can i mean and also this
could be done with
um i mean you could make a vegetarian
chili absolutely
any kind of thing you wanted with this
like this is the world is your
oyster and kind of go with it all right
we're going to figure out our next
recipe and thank you faraday go to
thedrewberrymarshow.com for the full
[Music]
recipe